hey chris has anyone been hurt by a jerk
lately
hey rocky yes uh we still get plenty of
cases regarding people that have been
injured especially in car crashes
um we handle cases where people that are
at fault or from
nevada or maybe it's a tourist from
coming up from arizona that drove up
here or even from california
well do you handle cases outside of las
vegas so i have clients that
live as far away as england that have
been hurt in las vegas
but i also have cases of nevada
residents where people that
were driving here were from other states
or from other states
so yes we handle cases not only in
nevada for nevada residents
and for tourists that are visiting
nevada but i also handle cases in
arizona and california and hawaii too
well that's good to know how often do
you get out of state cases
so primarily it's the cases that we get
from out of state
um at least as it relates to las vegas
it's the people that get into a lot of
crashes that are uh like on the highway
from
from like the hoover dam down to kingman
there's a lot of crashes on that highway
there's also quite a bit of crashes from
like prim to like
baker in east l.a right on the 15. we
get a lot of those cases as well
oh that makes sense i have seen those
really long lines of people heading back
to california on sundays
yeah it's crazy right we've seen that
like bumper to bumper traffic from las
vegas to prim
all the way up through the mountains
through sizzix road and
even baker but in those traffic lines
sometimes the traffic gets speed up
people get up to regular speeds again
they slow down they speed up people get
annoyed
or man they might be hungover or they're
just not paying attention they're in a
rush
and crashes happen all the time
absolutely so you can actually help
people even if the at fault driver is
from california or arizona
we do it all the time we can file a
lawsuit depending on where the accident
occurred whether it's in nevada
or whether it's in mohave county in
arizona when it's on that highway
regardless wherever somebody's been a
jerk whether it's an arizona jerk
a california jerk you just need to call
burke and we can help